christine is with us in Los Angeles hi
Christine how are you I am good how are
you better than I deserve how can I help
very good thank you for taking my call
you've just helped me tremendously
I started your plan in August and I have
a quick question for you okay so I'm on
board with the Dave Ramsey plan but my
husband is not she believes in like
making the minimum payment and keeping
the money in the bank so my husband and
I ever since we met and moved in and all
that we do our finances kind of funky we
keep our expenses income and bank
accounts completely separate we do
everything 5050 down the line we make
about the same amount per year so my
question is I'd like to eventually you
know after I finish baby step number
three to pay off our mortgage early
however both of our names are on it so
I'm not sure can I make an extra payment
and deduct that from the balance that I
owe or just save up the full amount and
then make a big one-time payment to pay
it off I'm not sure how to go about that
hmm or if that's even impossible and you
know it's not it's called join the serve
role you're liable for all of it not
half a night and so um and he's liable
for all of it not half of it and so
there's not a your half his half that's
the problem with trying to operate a
marriage like a roommate right how long
have you guys been married we've been
married since February but we've been
together and living together for 11
years and so the the problem is living
together put in place a pattern of
operating that is now bled over into
your marriage that is incorrect
all right because here's the problem
there's a lot of data out here
statistically that says you guys have
problems coming
uh-huh if you don't get on the same
page number one on the financial realm
it's very difficult not quite impossible
but very difficult to build wealth doing
what you're doing home number two it
leads to relational problems because you
know you're just leading separate lives
right you know the preacher says and now
you are one but you're not right you
didn't he pronounced you guys a roommate
you know no and now you are a
joint-venture you know it's way this
sounds and so you're not sharing your
future in your checkbook and so you're
not sharing your future and that tends
to HAP
sometimes it takes 10 years to bleed out
sometimes it takes 20 years to bleed out
but it always bleeds out eventually
meaning it always ends up harming most
of the time we're reparable ii the
relationship it's a trendline on the
data is just devastating it's not to say
can't be done but you are really on an
uphill battle to build wealth and have a
high quality marriage you're doing what
y'all are doing so I've got to just be
your friend and say I'm gonna demand as
your friend that you guys not do this
anymore that the two of you that you
that you fight the fight you don't want
to fight and and he had the discussion
he doesn't want to have that you have
got to get on the same page and combine
your finances and if that requires
marriage counseling that's fine and the
problem is you've done Dave Ramsey so
enthusiastically that now I'm a cuss
word in his head I paid quite a bit of
debt since starting in August and so
yeah and you've been enthusiastically
chasing after this thing and and he's
tired of hearing about it already to the
point that it's making the communication
that's difficult the idea of combining
it very difficult and so on but I think
you got to back up and start again and
just say a conversation that says that
it's very you know it's just concerning
me a lot
I understand I've been through see a
stick and understand I've been fired up
and I understand that that's off-putting
to you probably but this thing of us not
handling our money together it makes it
feel like we're not really married and I
really I think we were going to have to
work on this if we need to sit down with
a coach a marriage coach a marriage
counselor to help us get on the same
page then let's spend the money to do
that before it becomes a crisis in your
relationship right now you guys have
masked over it because what happened was
you got used to it when you were living
together and when you're living together
it's probably the best way to handle
let's keep it separate because you don't
have any you know the you don't have
them the legal protections of marriage
but once you're married you've got legal
protections from each other and as a
matter of fact they work against you in
this situation they work against keeping
it separate for instance the mortgage
thing we're talking about you can't pay
off half the mortgage because you own
the whole you owe the whole thing he
owes the whole thing and because they
view you the law view she was one as
married joint and several that's what
the law says and so that's one and your
joint but your one and and that's that
that's the issue so instead of trying to
figure out a way to make this bad system
work I would say I'd spend my energy
working on the bad system and say what
have we got to do to begin the
discussions negotiations or whatever it
is and love each other well enough to
say I'm gonna spend my life with you and
so I need to handle my money with you
and my money is your money and your
money is my money and how are we going
to do that because that says you're mine
and I'm yours that's a different level
of commitment that's a marital level of
commitment and that that's really what
you're up against here and and so you
know from a Christian viewpoint Jesus
said your treasure is where your heart
is so where you spend your money is
where your heart goes and when you have
two different directions that your
hearts are going that means your hearts
aren't together
you're not unified on your goals you're
not unified on your fears you're not you
unified on your value system of what
savings means and what debt means and
what giving and generosity means and
when you're unified on that then we're
there sure and I just prayed about last
weekend a sizable gift that we were
doing from a generosity standpoint and
you know we we had to talk it through
and it forced both of us to look at our
feelings about things it forced both of
us to have other discussions that
weren't even related to the gift but it
was a sizable thing and there's enough
money that it caused both of us to sit
up straight you know and when you sit up
straight like that and you're paying
attention it forms your relationship and
your marriage so I know a lot of people
think they can run separate accounts
there's just no data that says you can
and there's lots of data that says you
can't and I've been doing this 30 years
the number of times I've found someone
that raises from nothing and the couple
is married 10 20 years 30 years and
they've got 1015 million dollars and
they didn't do it together is almost
zero the number of times I have someone
to a debt free scream here on the air we
paid off a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
we paid off two hundred thousand dollars
in debt we paid off our house and the
spouse is not on board is almost zero
it's almost zero and I'm not just
preaching at you Christine I mean this
is just a good subject for our whole
list our listening audience to really
grasp and grapple with and it is the
danger of living together before
marriage because again you set patterns
in place to that now you're having to
reset and you have 11 years of doing it
as roommates and now to discuss doing it
as a married couple is weird but if you
were never living together before and
you just said hey we're getting married
that means we combine everything the
preacher says and now you are one and
the old marriage vows say unto thee all
my worldly goods I pledge I'm gonna take
care of you in sickness and in health
for richer for poorer you're gonna take
care of me
this is what marriage is and there's
something there that's really rich and
really real